hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another amnesia
custom story now this one is fear
amnesia which has been recommended a lot
by you guys and I saw that it is a score
of 9 point 4 which is pretty incredible
for a custom story and it's got about an
hour's worth of gameplay so this should
be a good one for you all to enjoy I've
been kind of distancing myself between
all the amnesia custom stories just get
myself room to breathe and get away from
it and then I can come back to it ready
to be scared again ok
fear amnesia is a horror and thrilling
house this custom story is to test your
fear instincts get out of the house if
you can and a dare creator of insanity
nocturnal confusion 1 and 2 okay I am
ready go ahead take your time game I am
in the odd end place to be or anything
to do I'm a busy man the Bell
okay well we're starting out with a bang
let's see what we got
nothing whole lot of nothing whoo custom
music I love it I love custom music in
the game okay
same old amnesia similar amnesia feel do
you fear are you afraid of the dark are
you willing to survive yeah do you think
you're brave enough who me do you think
you're able to find the truth maybe
nobody will ever known what happened
here oh god man can you okay it's a
shame when there's like a bunch of
custom working all that and really
really nice atmosphere custom music you
know it maybe even new monsters and
there's skilled typos it's just it's so
it's so degrading to the experience but
oh well I'll ignore it nothing there's
never anything in those things
okay so there's here we go here's a door
I have no lantern that's okay um oh hey
hi Spidey this seems like a pretty
decrepit house why am i living here that
is what I would like to know let's get
out of here I'm so scared
can't move the door with these chains
first I have to explore this house how
did you get in this house that's what
I'm wondering I would throw a stricken
chair through the window and get the eff
out of here
what's with that it's weird I did okay
down normal was that it's a giant ass
knife not a giant ass knife a giant ass
knife gotta watch where you're - Tsar Oh
Oh
it's like goopy bits of people
who's this someone just like explode and
why why this doesn't make any sense yeah
okay whatever hi is something happening
now this is where reality decides to
unravel least I have a lantern but no
oil a music the music's pretty loud
Locke has to be a key somewhere
no bust in that little alcove okay ah
what what just happened
did I just black out for a second there
I'm so confused
I'm alright uh breaking pots and pans
how boring I am wondering why this chest
is just where these dressers like right
there closet also known as a closet so
far it's like really cool I like it a
lot
found a machine uh hello baby
oh how you doing hi
oh you lose Oh fine I know I've been
away a while I know I know baby but I'll
be back
I gotta explore the rest of the house
don't worry I'll be here I'll be here
I'll come back for you okay
No ah finally some oil not that I needed
it's been pretty good about not throwing
me into total pitch blackness ooh ah
that's much better
there's something up here I thought I
saw something up here that I could climb
up to but apparently not hang on let me
check again just to make sure there's
nothing like a key up here special items
no okay nevermind alright that actually
provides quite a lot of light I like
that huh but nice catch
okay now that it's much brighter in here
because of that one thing I should be
good to continue exploring hahaha
hi mr. barrel you're not a monster Oh
oooh oh this whole place doesn't look
good
ah oh uh hell that's normal I need to
find a bucket filled with water to
extinguish the fire I feel like there's
something in the Attic I need to find
that key these planks are in the way I
must get rid of them somehow okay so
that relates to the window the roof
and this fire and magic portal thingy
anything over there
goodbye goodbye thank you what is that
is that steam I hear I'm not sure more
oil
thank you oh please open open open I
don't know where this quote-unquote
machine room is and I don't know how I'm
gonna get up there one second
I can get up here Boosh yeah anything
anything nope okay that was a waste of
time sanity lost sanity potions but I'm
doing just fine or not or I'm not fine
haha
oh is that okay I am NOT saying at all
okay I have the key to that machine room
but let me just look around a bit more
maybe I can trigger another episode of
PTSD good God
all right what do we got here ow extreme
heat steam ha ha
extreme heat steam some I mean I
understand that this was probably made
by not someone who speaks in English
natively or if it was why that's real
sad okay anyway um I think I can go up
to the machine room now all right let's
go
I mean no no no no padlock I need a key
for that yeah I just did thank you
it's awfully loud in here you're rank
nope
yep there must be some clues around here
to stop this machine well thank you so
much
machine manual god you're such a dick
okay whatever fine machine manual is
just some guy like god I wish I knew how
to write this my boss is gonna kill me
if I don't write up this manual I'm
gonna write something oh no can't use
this lever if the machine is still
running okay let's just pull wildly yeah
yeah that'll do uh-huh that driving new
anymore really really helpful clues
anywhere you big sons of [ __ ] ah no
that didn't help me at all
oh must stop the machine upstairs first
okay that's great that's just great
down Wow
oh yes yeah I get it
I don't know how but I did it yes mmm
I'm the credit God birth ha ha ha ha oh
man
believe it or not that was guesswork
those total guesswork and I am the man
oh great
oh oh I gotta grab it off of his
dingdong house is that what you stupid
[ __ ]
you stupid pieces you not is so
arbitrary and stupid you mother I would
never do that I need to find some rope
some rope with a magnet you are so dumb
oh you're so dumb dude come on
am I in the cellar is this a cellar I
gotta find it in here please tell me
it's in here I'm so scared at the little
ghost girl dad I just couldn't couldn't
take it anymore I just threw it into the
water I wanted to die No well here's
some rope but I guess this isn't the
right rope loud down Adam um yeah I
guess these rope aren't the correct ones
so I'm not gonna use them this is the
cellar correct this is you could say the
cellar right in this cellar yeah rope
with a magnet
I'm gonna find a rope with a magnet do
people even have rare earth magnets here
in this time period I'm sure they did
but probably not readily available and
attached to ropes
maybe was in the machine room somewhere
oh that's so stupid
that's so stupid I'm so stupid what is
this that was for nothing
that was for absolutely nothing all
right it's gotta be somewhere let's just
look around very carefully right nope
nope nope it's not in this area here
it's not over here not here it wasn't in
these drawers I know that it wasn't back
there maybe wait maybe I could get
weight I would probably be able to get
over there but never get back I don't
want to do that yeah I don't want to do
that that's that's a dumb that's a dumb
idea
I know dumb ideas I'm all about the dumb
ideas anything back here come on
where'd a frigging rope with a magnet
how do I even know a rope with a magnet
is here ha oh it went right through
amazing ok not in here definitely not in
here ok not in here not back here
anything back there let me just get a
get a box here and just double check to
be sure gonna be wandering around
forever because you guys know how much I
love to be lost nothing here nothing
here nothing you're not this rope not
this bowl not anything here nothing on
here nothing down here nothing over here
on this shelf what about that no
anything up there no I'm wasting oil
good that's what I love to do as I've
said before whenever you're playing
amnesia make sure you always use your
lantern even if it's like brightest day
out even if you're in the daylight use
the lantern it helps keep some monsters
away anything in here anything at all
anything no good wouldn't want to make
it too easy on myself how about this
from no great fantastic I love my life
anything behind this no ha ha that would
have been too easy ok great I'm still
playing the game still trying to find a
damn rope on up Oh mother I can't find
it dad nothing down here it's all a lie
all one big lie is it ding-dong damn lie
there's no rope there's no rope there's
no rope on string it's all a lie it's a
big fat lie
this games a big phony games a big fat
phony wait oh no I thought I saw
something glowing blue okay well this is
dumb it's added that basement but
there's obviously in my nose itches
ah God why does everything bad happen to
me I can't find it I can't find it
ladies and gentlemen out there ladies
and gentlemen in the audience watching
me fail at finding rope with a magnet on
it you can tell that I am trying but I'm
just not trying hard enough
I am not worthy to succeed I didn't look
up though so maybe I'll look up a bit
and I'll find it dangling from the
ceiling nope uh-uh
okay so I cannot find it so you guys are
gonna have to help me write in the
comment section where it is like yeah Oh
mark you still do videos right there
siya just forget okay so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
ha
you
love